nos dan dos matrices aquí la matriz
y la matriz de y nos dicen que es de la
cual es otra manera de decir cuál es el
producto de la matriz e y la matriz de y
sólo para recordar lo que estoy haciendo
déjame copiar esto y pegar esto
y luego voy a sacar mi
y luego voy a sacar mi pequeño blog de
apuntes así que déjame pegar eso por
aquí
para que tengamos toda la información
que necesitamos así que intentemos
resolver esto es la matriz
por la matriz de por lo que esta es la
matriz
por la matriz la matriz d
lo que es igual
la matriz y es todo esto entonces es
por la matriz de que es todo esto por lo
que multiplicamos por 3
- 2 y - 2
ahora lo primero que necesitamos
comprobar es si esta es una operación
válida la multiplicación de matrices es
una gran operación definida por el
humano como todas las demás operaciones
que tiene propiedades ahora la manera en
la que como humanos tenemos que
encontrar la multiplicación de matrices
sólo funciona si estamos multiplicando
nuestras dos matrices esta de aquí tiene
dos filas tres columnas por lo que es
una matriz de dos x
y esta tiene tres filas y dos columnas
así que es 3
x
y esto sólo funciona nosotros sólo
podemos multiplicar esta matriz por esta
matriz si el número de columnas en esta
matriz es igual al número de filas de
esta matriz
y en esta situación se cumple por lo que
puedo de hecho multiplicar las si estos
dos números no fueran iguales si el
número de columnas aquí no fuera igual
al número de filas aquí esta no sería
una operación válida por lo menos en la
manera en la que hemos definido la
multiplicación de matrices otro punto
que hay que recordar es que 'por de no
siempre es lo mismo que de x y el orden
importa si estás multiplicando matrices
no afecta si estás multiplicando números
convencionales pero importa para las
matrices
así que empecemos a trabajar en esto lo
que vamos a obtener lo que vamos a
obtener de hecho va a ser una matriz de
2 por 2 pero haré un poco de espacio
aquí porque tenemos que hacer algunos
cálculos así que esto va a ser igual a
esto va a ser igual a haré una gran
matriz de 2 por 2 aquí
la manera en la que obtenemos la entrada
de arriba izquierda
la entrada de arriba izquierda va de
hecho a ser va a ser esta fila va a ser
ésta
fila por este producto
si estás familiarizado con los vectores
y con el producto punto vamos de hecho a
hacer el producto punto de eso y eso si
no tienes idea de lo que es eso estoy a
punto de mostrarte
esta entrada va a ser cero por tres así
que es cero por tres más tres por tres
x
+ 5 x 4
por 4 así que esa es la entrada de
arriba izquierda y ahora podemos hacer
la entrada de arriba derecha esta fue la
de arriba izquierda y ahora haremos la
de arriba derecha así que la entrada de
arriba derecha va a ser va a ser esta
fila
esta fila por esta columna esta fila por
esta columna
note que la entrada está obteniendo la
fila de la primera matriz y la columna
de la segunda eso está determinando su
posición así que una vez más será 0 x 4
pero por 4-3 por menos 2
x
menos 25 por menos 2
5 x menos 2
y si seguimos la entrada de abajo
izquierda va a ser esta fila la segunda
fila de aquí
por la primera columna de aquí
entonces es 5 x 3
5 x 35 x 3
5 x
más dos por cuatro más dos por cuatro y
ya casi terminamos solo tenemos que
multiplicar o más bien obtener el
producto punto de esta fila
con esta columna de aquí
así que va a ser 5 x 4
5 x 4
5 x menos 2
2 x menos dos más
2 x menos 2
por lo que esto va a ser igual a y solo
tenemos que evaluar esto ahora veamos
0 por 13 0 esto es 9 + 20 esto es
29 todo esto se simplifica
20 9 todo esto es 0 esto es
y esto es menos 10
por lo que todo esto se simplifica a
menos 16
-16
esto de aquí es 15 por 15 que es 30 más
8 así que esto es 38 y
y finalmente esto es 20
- 10
- 4 así que esto será 6 por lo que todo
esto se simplificará a
así que todo esto se convirtió en 29 16
38 y 6 29
16 38 y 6
entonces es 29 29
-16
y 6
comprobemos nuestra respuesta la tuvimos
bien